who funds our politics and our
politicians today Sky News and our
partners tortoise media set out to try
and answer that question the Westminster
accounts project helps us and you to
follow the money
the current system involves stacks of
documents and databases is this really
the transparency the public has been
promised we've combined them into one
tool that anyone can use and it allows
us to show you what we never could
before over 17 million pounds that the
total amount of outside earnings the MPS
have declared in the course of this
Parliament just three years and it's on
top of their annual 84 000 pound salary
and this might be one reason why reform
is so hard when a Tory government's in
number 10 of the 17 million 15 million
pounds in earnings made by MPS goes to
conservatives now for the first time we
can sort MPS in order of what they make
from second jobs and other outside
earnings this here is the leaderboard
these people the top 20 made close to
two-thirds of all the outside earnings
in this Parliament the MP with the most
separate sources of outside income
Labor's Shadow foreign secretary David
Lammy earning over 200
000 pounds from a radio show and
corporate speeches
not clear how that fits with his party
leaders proposed ban on second jobs but
interviewed on Sky news this morning
kirstarma backing our push to open up
the system the ball transparency the
better celebrity can see exactly what
has been declared and ask whatever
questions they want and the suggesting
exceptions from his second job span
could apply to his shadow foreign
secretary's earnings David for example
does a lot of media work and I think
media work and writing books is all part
of the political process but there's a
discussion to be had what I was urging
was for the whole House of Commons to
agree new rules because I do think that
we should get rid of second jobs with
some exceptions the health Minister an
example of the kind of second job that
almost all MPS support I'm a nurse I
still work as a nurse I declare those
earnings on my website and I think it's
important that people are able to keep
their interests in that sort of field
going all of us thank lady Theresa May
for her time the highest earning MP in
this Parliament former prime minister
Theresa May she's earned over two and a
half million pounds from speeches like
this one in Saudi Arabia paid a hundred
and seven thousand Pounds to address a
travel conference
[Applause]
spent weeks trying to get answers from
Theresa May about her outside work with
no luck
her constituents ready to make up their
mind there we go that's a lot of money
so I I think if she's more focused on
doing that than being a teacher MP
certainly will affect it MP should be
doing that doing their job and not
getting involved in all these other
things you know it all depends what
she's talking about
if somebody wants to pay money to her
who's to say why not
many are willing to put their money into
our political system but who and why
tomorrow we investigate donors in the
next chapter of the Westminster accounts